en una de mis películas favoritas si
tuviera 30 hay una escena donde se
encuentra la actriz jennifer con quien
interpreta a llena se encuentra
conversando con git baker nissan esta
actriz que le da vida a la mamá de dicho
personaje en un momento de incertidumbre
de llena la mamá le dice algo así como
hija hasta las más pequeñas e
insignificantes decisiones pueden
cambiar todo cada sendero que tomas te
lleva a una nueva elección algunas de
ellas pueden cambiar todo cada momento
de tu vida qué crees depende de ello a
lo que llena pregunta alguna vez pero
alguna vez te has arrepentido de un
terrible error y la mamá le dice no
porque de no haberme equivocado
jamás hubiera aprendido a hacer las
cosas bien
durante mi época de secundaria mi primer
año yo comienzo en el turno vespertino
dura aproximadamente unos tres meses
después me dan el cambio al turno de la
mañana y al paso de unos días decidió
cometer un acto de vandalismo mis
compañeros del turno de la tarde me
dejaban mensajes de cariño rayando las
bancas todos los días yo llegaba muy
contenta me encontraba con un nuevo
mensaje porque porque todos los días yo
les contestaba de la misma manera
rayando las bancas del salón que los
extrañaba mucho una compañera muy
comunicativa del salón le dice mi
profesora de español que yo estaba
rayando las bandas la profesoras ensayar
y no y delante de todo el salón me gritó
que era una banda la que era una chola
sin educación en ese momento sentí que
se me iba a venir el mundo encima y que
era mi final que me iban a correr me
sentí tan culpable de aquella decisión
de haber dañado con mis 12 años el
mobiliario
pero esta decisión que parece alomejor
insignificante a mí me marcó
tremendamente esa anécdota hasta el día
de hoy me acompaña pues me dio la
oportunidad de reflexionar y de darme
cuenta que en esta vida a lo largo de mi
vida lleva a tomar decisiones por
emoción por rutina o buena estrategia
que podrían darme que podrían no darme
el resultado que yo esperaba y podrían
hacerme sentir muy culpable y muy
frustrada pero que siempre más adelante
yo iba a tener la oportunidad de decidir
de decidir nuevamente eso fue lo que
hice de vandal a como me dijo mi
profesora pase a ser la presidenta la
sociedad de alumnos y tres veces
campeona del estado de chihuahua en
oratoria
quiero que pensemos muchas veces con
esta anécdota quiero decirles a ustedes
que yo llegué a una conclusión de que en
esta vida
no existen ni malas ni buenas decisiones
lo que sí existe es el tomar decisiones
no me refiero a aquellas decisiones
referentes a infringir la ley a dañar a
terceras personas o decisiones
patológicas sino aquellas decisiones muy
personales que nos han puesto aquí el
día de hoy regalándonos una increíble
enseñanza un día vi a un chico caminando
lo vi porque se me hizo guapo después me
quedé viendo a su camiseta muy
interesante que decía malas decisiones
hacen buenas historias y yo dije que yo
soy muy clavada en todo lo que veo
entonces dije como una mala decisión
puede llevarte algo positivo
me fui pensando malas decisiones hacen
buenas historias malas decisiones de ser
buenas historias y yo llegué a mi propia
conclusión por mis experiencias y las
experiencias de las personas a mi
alrededor que en esta vida no hay mala
decisión
nosotros los humanos
definimos una decisión como humana
cuando ésta no nos da el resultado que
nosotros esperábamos
pensemos en cuando éramos niños cuánto
nos frustra vamos o pensábamos en una
decisión que tomábamos creo que ni
siquiera sabíamos dado la definición de
decisión cuando llegamos a la
adolescencia y a la vida adulta esto
cambia completamente comenzamos a ser
más conscientes obviamente de lo que nos
rodea
comenzamos a frustrar nos muchas veces
por eso por aquellas decisiones pero a
veces también esas decisiones una vez ya
como adultos comienzan a estar comienzan
a tener una influencia por factores
externos como lo es ahí está nuestra
decisión en esa gráfica que ustedes
pueden observar pero en ella hay familia
hay hay miedos hay traumas
hay experiencias hay prejuicios y hay
tradición que ponen muchas veces una
presión muy importante en lo que
nosotros decidimos
por qué
cuántas veces no nos ha pasado que
tomamos una decisión que decimos bueno
no era lo que yo esperaba
y decimos voy a tratar de cambiar esa
situación creo que hay una elección que
que puedo hacer nuevamente pero qué pasa
cuando personas a nuestro alrededor
comienzan a juzgar nuestras decisiones
hasta clasificarlas como humanas y
holland que emana esa decisión a veces
nos sentimos más mal de lo que ya nos
sentíamos porque comienzan estos
prejuicios
esto es estas creencias de las personas
no quiero platicarles esta anécdota de
un hombre que yo conocí una vez que me
dice sabe que mi hija yo siempre quise
abrir un negocio pero nunca me decidí a
hacerlo ahora ya que estoy viejo tengo
mi fondo de ahorros como fondo de
ahorros decidí abrir un negocio pero
sabe que no me dio los retos que yo
esperaba y no me sentí mal pues al
contrario me sentí muy bien porque tomé
esa decisión que me tardo tanto
tomar pero sabe porque sabe
me sentí mal cuando mi esposa
mis amigos mi familia comenzaron a
decirme de que qué mala decisión
qué mal que había invertido si ya tenía
mi vejez asegurada fue cuando me sentí
mal verdaderamente hasta que un día me
levanté y dije nomás se acabó
fui y me dio un préstamo al banco
nuevamente decidir reabrir mi negocio en
otra área de la ciudad y que cree
ahorita este negocio es próspero aquí en
nuestra ciudad
cuántas veces no nos pasa que escuchamos
este tipo de escenarios o incluso
escuchamos muchas veces yo a mi
alrededor mi familia amigos conocidos de
que viven culpándose porque no siguen
sus sueños porque no estudiaron algo que
ellos querían estudiar porque se casaron
muy jóvenes porque tuvieron hijos muy
jóvenes y pienso yo bueno pero aquí
sigues y aún hay tiempo en que nos
estamos verdaderamente nosotros como
humanos enfocando en aquello que dicen o
no dicen los demás o en aquello que
llamamos problema
a consecuencia de mi decisión o en la
solución que le puedo dar yo a mi
situación actual y es que nuestro
enfoque es lo que va a determinar cómo
nosotros nos sentimos y lo más mágico y
lo que a veces no vemos es que allá
adelante hay siempre una decisión nueva
esperándonos y que quizá vamos a fallar
sí muy probable pero podemos volver a
intentar aún con más experiencia
creo que es momento de que abracemos
esas decisiones que hemos tomado y no
nos debemos sentirnos orgullosos porque
estas decisiones nos han dado
experiencia y una experiencia nunca es
un fracaso pues siempre viene a
demostrarnos algo y vean que tienen que
no lo digo yo lo dijo el gran científico
thomas alva edison
dejemos de voltear hacia atrás y de
culparnos y aquellas decisiones que
hemos tomado
traemos tanto en un costal a veces
cargando allí arrastrando un costalito
de negatividad de sentimientos que no
nos dejan avanzar y ese fue mi caso por
eso creo que debemos también dejar de
lado esas creencias que no nos impulsan
y nos limitan una creencia que tenemos
es el tiempo el tiempo como nos pasa a
todos y hacerme fue el tiempo ya para
que ya para que vuelvo a decidir ya se
me fue el tiempo en mi caso a mí me pasó
que yo comencé a estudiar una profesión
que no era lo que yo quería la verdad no
estaba contenta pero yo decía cómo voy a
empezar nuevamente oa estudiar algo si
ya se me fue todo este tiempo
invirtiendo en esta carrera la gente me
decía si era dicha quédate ahí ya
terminé esa carrera ya para que hasta
que el geno suficiente decidí tomar la
decisión será autónoma con mi decisión y
cambiarme a una profesión que puedo
decir ahorita me hace muy feliz sin
embargo no me arrepiento de aquel tiempo
que que yo puse de esfuerzo y de empeño
en una carrera
carrera diferente porque aprendí
bastante también
esa es esa toma esa decisión que yo hice
me permitió darme cuenta que no puedo
arrepentirme de nada que haya sido mi
propia decisión y lo bonito de todo esto
es que con esa decisión pude tomar
nuevamente otra decisión que fue irme
lejos de esta ciudad de esa frontera que
tanto amo lejos de mi familia de mis
amigos y tomar la decisión así sin
pensar la de irme lejos de la ciudad y
comenzar a trabajar
en el otro en otra ciudad me llaman
ofrecen el trabajo sin pensar la digo
que si me subí a mi carro eché mi ropa
mis zapatos y siempre digo muchos pero
muchos sueños me acompañaron 10 horas
manejando sola hasta la ciudad de corpus
christi una vez que llego allá no había
conseguido donde quedarme no tenía
familia no tenía amigos
no sabía qué hacer lo único que pensé
llegue a la playa y en la ciudad y ahora
que hago lo más lógico inventé una
habitación en un hotel me lo pague por
adelantado me quedé ahí unos cuantos
días cada vez que quería yo irme a mi
trabajo tenía que echarme un clavado en
una tremenda maleta que compré ahí muy
baratas con los chinos para echarte en
el centro del paso ahí echar todas mis
cosas me tiene que echar un clavado la
maletera tan grande que no la podía
bajar yo sola entonces era tomar mi ropa
subir a mi cuarto del hotel planchar mi
ropa y lista para irme a trabajar con
todas mis cosas que ocupaban el asiento
del copiloto de mi carro los asientos de
atrás y ahí voy yo parecía que iba a
vender fayuca lola la trailera se
imaginarán me decían pero tú que vienes
a vender al trabajo yo con tremenda
vergüenza decía ay dios mío qué pena
bueno es uno de menos piedritas por aquí
piedritas por allá seguían saliendo en
mi camino yo estaba estresada y
frustrada y así lo dije qué mala
decisión no me dije pero como se me
ocurrió venirme a
dije pero o sea ya tenía mi familia
comida calientita de la abuelita mis
amigos todo que me vine a batallar
pero hoy que pienso dije que bueno que
no pensé demasiado en aquella decisión
porque quizás nunca me hubiera ido y no
me hubiera aventurado algo que me dejó
experiencias únicas en mi vida me hacía
lo desconocido sin tener nada y regresé
a esta frontera nuevamente con las manos
más llenas hoy veo los frutos la
recompensa de aquella decisión
con 22 años hace un año tuve la
oportunidad de personalmente conocer
personas increíbles con las que tengo un
vínculo de amistad único que hasta hoy
en día se toman el tiempo de llamarme
para saber cómo estoy
logré cubrir una visita presidencial la
llegada de un huracán y yo no estaba
preparada para eso yo lo sabía que
profesionalmente no lo estaba como nunca
estaba preparada para tomar ninguna de
las decisiones que he tomado sin embargo
hay a mi lado tenía personas
profesionales que que me demostraron y
me enseñaron lo que ellos ya sabían
creo que es importante que abracemos hay
que sonreír a esas decisiones que hemos
tomado yo en mi caso soy una persona muy
muy emocional
este que a veces me cuesta mucho tomar
tomar decisiones porque soy muy
emocional sin embargo me dado cuenta que
en esta vida muchas de las elecciones
que he hecho me están preparando quizá
porque en determinado momento a lo mejor
voy a tener que tomar una decisión de
vida muerte yo no sé si vaya a ser su
caso o vaya a ser mi caso pero el de mi
abuelo si lo fue mi abuelo fue
diagnosticado con cáncer de esófago
terminal
un médico le dice señor
en la opción que yo le tengo es una
cirugía colocarle una endoprótesis
esofágica algo así como una especie de
tubo para permitir el paso de los
alimentos que de acuerdo a nuestro
diagnóstico podría dejarlo vivir
aproximadamente unos nueve meses de vida
con calidad otro médico le dice señor le
tenemos la opción de una quimioterapia
estoy de acuerdo del cambio a nuestro
diagnóstico podría erradicar
completamente las células del cáncer
cuál de las dos decisiones hubieran
tomado ustedes cuál decisión era buena o
mala decisión hermana mía vuelo auto por
una segunda opción la quimioterapia la
cual se esperaba que erradicar a las
células del cáncer sin embargo
esta decisión esta opción solamente le
permitió vivir tres meses de vida y la
mayoría del tiempo dentro de un hospital
en mi caso comencé a cuestionarme y a
preguntarme y a frustrarme qué hubiera
pasado si mi abuelo hubiera tomado la
primera opción hubiera vivido unos meses
más con calidad de vida y no
visiblemente deteriorado física y
mentalmente pero estoy segura que si mi
abuelo hubiera elegido la cirugía y no
la quimioterapia que se lo llevó en tres
meses mis preguntas hubieran sido las
mismas porque no sabía cuál era buena o
cuál era mala decisión
estoy segura conocía también a mi abuelo
que si él estuviera que ahorita me diría
que lo que él decidió en ese momento fue
lo que él creyó mejor para él
y es que son y es que son justamente eso
nuestras decisiones son momentos de la
vida que hay que aprender a abrazar
rompamos ese paradigma que existe en
malas decisiones dejemos de ser tan
severos con nosotros mismos por por todo
lo que hemos elegido eso es lo que nos
ha formado en mi caso les decía yo soy
una persona muy emocional yo no conozco
la inteligencia emocional
cada vez que tengo que tomar una
decisión si es el momento si es más
adelantito o si es a largo plazo trato
de no pensar mucho entre sí lleno
y al final de cuentas esa decisión no me
dé el resultado que yo esperaba trato de
ser consecuente con mi decisión y volver
a intentar y si me vuelvo a caer vuelvo
a intentar nuevamente
muchas de las veces a mí también me ha
pasado como ustedes quizás que me he
culpado por mis decisiones me han
llevado a sentirme deprimida a sentir
que no tengo salida pero me pregunto y
digo quién de nosotros venimos con
normal un manual incluido bajo el brazo
que nos diga qué decisiones tomar y qué
decisiones no tomar en esa vida
cuando tomo yo una decisión
pienso trato de no pensar mucho
nuevamente entre sí lleno
prefiero tomar una decisión a no
quedarme con la incertidumbre de que
hubiera pasado
si no hubiera tomado aquella decisión
prefiero elegir algo y si no me da el
resultado que yo esperaba sé que hay
almas adelante y nuevas decisiones
esperándome y si están ustedes ahorita y
sentados pensando que es muy tarde
el tiempo se me fue estoy muy viejo muy
vieja para tomar nuevas decisiones y
cambiar mi rumbo y cambiar mi entorno
quiero que piensen en el coronel david
sanders este hombre y magnífico que a
los 16 años decidió dejar la escuela uy
qué mala decisión tenían muchos aquí a
los 18 años decide dejarlo decide que
antes y de casarse contra muy mala
decisión después del poco tiempo deciden
tener hijos pésimo ya nada más va a
vivir para los hijos muy mala decisión
tan joven poco tiempo después su esposa
lo deja
pero sin dejar de ir la oportunidad
continuar tomando y tomando decisiones
ya la mejor creer en el camino y sentir
que el mundo se le iba a acabar siguió y
siguió y siguió y nunca dejó que nunca
dejó ir la oportunidad de tomar
decisiones fue así como con 88 años se
convirtió en lo que tú y hoy cosa que
quisiéramos ser un hombre millonario
y si todavía tú estás ahí sentado y
estás pensando y volviendo al pasado
desde en todas las de todas aquellas
elecciones que tú tomaste
te invito a que nada más cuantías
tantito pero para acordarte de aquellas
decisiones que creíste que eran el fin
del mundo y no lo fueron al contrario
estás aquí sentado el día de hoy y si
traes un costal un morral ahí lleno de
culpas de negatividad de sentimientos
quiero que te acuerdes y te lleves este
poema purépecha que dice esto de la vida
en la vida ni se gana ni se pierde ni se
fracasa ni se triunfa en la vida se
aprende se crece se descubren se escribe
se borra y se reescribe otra vez
sehila se desfila y se buen baile el día
que comprendí que lo único que me voy a
llevar es lo que vivo empecé a vivir lo
que me quiero llevar
[Aplausos]